So for practice
with expectation,
let's calculate the expected
number of heads in n coin
flips, and just working
directly from the definition,
because we have
tools to do that.
So we're imagining n independent
flips of a coin with bias p.
So the coins might not be fair.
The probability of heads is p.
It would be biased in favor of
heads if p is greater than 1/2
and biased against heads
if p is less than 1/2.
And we want to know how
many heads are expected.
This is a basic question that
will come up again and again
when we look at random variables
and probability theory.
So what's the expected
number of heads?
Well, we already know--
we've examined the binomial
distribution B n,p.
B n,p is telling us how
many heads there are in n
independent flips.
So we're asking about the
expectation of the binomial
variable B n,p.
Well, let's look
at the definition.
The definition of B n,p is it's
the sum over all the possible
values of B, namely all
the numbers from 0 to n--
that's k-- of the probability
of getting k heads.
And this formula here
is the probability
of getting k heads, which
we've worked out previously.
n choose k times p to the k,
1 minus p to the n minus k.
Well, let's introduce
an abbreviation,
a standard abbreviation.
Let's replace 1 minus p by q,
where-- so p plus q equals 1,
and they're both not
negative and between 0 and 1.
And when I express the
expectation this way,
it starts to look like
something a little bit familiar.
And our strategy is going to
be to use the binomial theorem,
and then the trick
of differentiating it
is going to wind up
giving us a closed
formula for this expression
for the expectation
of the binomial random variable.
So let's remember the
binomial theorem says
that the nth power of x
plus y is the sum all from k
equals 0 to n of n choose k, x
to the k, y to the n minus k.
And if I differentiate
this, what
happens is that on
the left hand side,
if I differentiate with
respect to x, I get x plus y
to the n minus 1 times n.
And if I differentiate the
right hand side-- let's
differentiate it term by term.
And differentiating
with respect to x
is going to turn this n choose
k x to the k, y to the n minus k
into an x to the k
minus 1 times k term.
But I'd like to keep
the n-- the k here
and the k there matching.
So that after
differentiating, that
becomes an x to the k minus 1.
Let's multiply it by x
to make it x to the k.
And of course, I have to undo
that multiplication by dividing
the whole thing by 1/x.
So by differentiating
the binomial formula,
we get the following formula
for this sum that is starting
to look just like the
expectation of B n,p,
1/x times the sum from k equals
0 to 1 of k times n choose k,
x to the k, y to the n minus k.
Well, let's compare
the two terms.
So here's this term
and there's this one.
I'm going to replace this line
by the formula for expectation
of the binomial random variable.
So this is what we're
trying to evaluate,
and I have this great theorem.
You can see how they match up.
So what I'm going to do is
replace p and q-- replace
x and y in this
general formula that I
got by differentiating the
binomial theorem with p and q.
And what happens?
So I just plug in the p and q.
Now, the left hand
side. p plus q is 1.
So the left hand side
is going to become n.
And this right hand side now
is exactly the expectation of B
n,p-- this part of it, anyway.
So what I'm going to wind up
with is that n is equal to 1/p
times the expectation of B n,p.
In other words, the expectation
of B n,p is n times p,
and that is the basic formula
that we were deriving by first
principles without using
any general properties
of expectation, just the
definition of expectation
and the stuff that we had
already worked out in terms
of the binomial theorem.